Wow. This room?
Yeah. You okay?
I just got me thinking about the empty house
we first moved into.
Couple of newlyweds planning a cross-country
trip, but I kept getting morning sickness.
And six months later.
Wow. Wow.
Wow. You carry two boxes, Dylan.
I carry two humans.
Yes. Poppy and George.
Who else?
We got the hang of it pretty fast.
Yeah, we were feeling pretty smart for a
while.
I'm on the phone with the landlord in Geneva.
The apartment he has is four and a half by
11m. Quick.
What does that work out to in square
footage?
Oh, no, no, no, I'm still here.
Bigger than, bigger than.
Well. Oh, do you have.
This was kind of ridiculous.
I have to get back. Oh, no. I was just
following the path of this fly.
Oh, I'll do it. Okay, give me a second.
Oh.
Which one of you has the steadiest hands?
Oh, Luke, we got a second key the last time
that happened. It's in the kitchen door.
Come on.
So that's pretty much 25 years of
uninterrupted crazy.
And then when it ends.
It ends.
Until our next chapter.
I'm just brainstorming here, but maybe we
take a long delayed RV trip across the
United States, get selfies with all the
Major League Baseball mascots.
You must really love you, because that sounds
fun. They're
really leaving. What do we do?
People have always done.
Leave the porch light on, they come back.
Everyone. I would like to say a few words
before our car comes two simple words.
Actually, thank you for making me feel so
welcome in this family.
I love you.
A family that taught me so much from Jay.
I learned to get to the point from Little
Joe.
We only have a few minutes. Why don't why
don't we take that family picture, huh?
Okay, let's do that. All right.
Great idea, I got him.
Hey, I know people tend to get mushy in
moments like this, but with you headed
around the world and me headed off to
college.
We'll stay close.
How come you never wrote a poem for me?
Don't you get it?
They were all for you.
You get the sombrero?
What are you, know your masculine.
What is wrong with you?
What are you talking about?
You're acting crazy and it's scaring me.
You're too young to be acting like an old
man.
I'm old Viejo.
Huh?
Estoy aprendiendo espanol para TI sorpresa.
Mi amor. I've been using this app, you know,
so I'll know what's going on when I go with
you to Colombia this summer.
You're coming.
You've been staring at my family for 12
years. At least I can do is stare at yours
for one summer.
You're wonderful.
But no staring.
And never, ever take the same route twice.
Oh, yeah. You're going to love it.
Okay, everybody squeeze in.
Squeeze in for the picture.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Okay.
All right.
Perfect. I got it, okay.
I kind of don't want to let go.
Yeah. Me neither.
I mean, it's Mitch and Cam now, but these
three next.
Who knows when we'll all be together again?
Why is this so hard?
We've done this, like, seven times already
today.
It's hard because not everybody gets to have
what we have.
Mitchell. I put the skating trophy in your
suitcase and want you to have it first, so
that I know you'll come back.
Okay. I'm going to set an example and be the
first one to let go.
It was awful.
Life is full of change.
Some big, some small. I learned a long time
ago, you can fight it or you can try to make
the best of it. And that's all a lot easier
if you've got people who love you, helping
you face whatever life throws at you.
At least that's what helps me sleep at
night.